dr thomas aßmann mir nun zugeschaltet
guten tag erstmal ja die nächsten 48
durch den nächsten 48 stunden das hören
wir jetzt immer wieder warum sind genau
diese so entscheidend aus medizinischer
sicht also man muss so sagen ich bin 900
nächsten 48 stunden sondern wirklich bis
freitag müssen wir gucken weil die der
tag 7 bis 10 7 bis 11 nach infektion bis
der kritische zeitpunkt wo die schwere
nebenwirkungen wie luftnot wie atemwegs
schwierigkeiten und komplikationen
eintreten können also der us-präsident
dem scheint es ja anscheinend relativ
gut zu gehen
der ist aber nicht nur um berg weil die
kritische zeit wie gesagt kommen wird
und wenn sie gucken die meisten
todesfälle bzw auch die meisten fälle
die dann auf intensivstationen kamen und
dann beatmet werden mussten war in
dieser kritischen phase sieben bis elf
und wir müssen natürlich uns auch fragen
wie sieht es nach dieser infektion aus
ist dann donald trump wieder der alte
oder ist der handicap für die ganze zeit
des wahlkampfes aufgrund seiner
erkrankung natürlich dann schon zur
risikogruppe als männlich höheren alters
und auch übergewichtig wie gefährlich
kann diese erkrankung also finden werden
um die wahrscheinlich sind dann auch
spätfolgen
also muss ganz klar sagen die erkrankung
für ihn ist lebensbedrohlich punkt
einfach das muss man gleich auch noch
mal jedem sagen wir sehen ist jetzt
gerade da dran an diesem ereignis das in
kuwait erreger ist völlig egal ist bist
du weißt bist du schwarz ist mächtig
oder ohnmächtig hast du geld oder nicht
wenn du dich nicht an den regeln es
macht er dich krank und diese erkrankung
ist eben bei patienten über 60 oft sehr
schwerwiegend ja wir jetzt wegen ist
trump das problem wie sehen die nächsten
tage aus man muss einfach sagen die
risikobehafteten dass er daran schwerst
erkrankt auch virtuell versteht es
einfach an dieser gruppe deutlich höher
und natürlich auch die neben
wirkungsgrad sprich wie wird es dann
sein in nach seiner kampf wir sprechen
ja auch nicht mehr von heilung sondern
von genesung weil wenn wir sehen dass
menschen trotz 34
doch nach der akuten corona erkrankung
noch unter den spätfolgen leiden wie zb
verlangsamung demenz zeichen die
schwächen und so weiter und so weiter
also das ist alles sehr dramatisch
das haben wir ja angaben gehört über den
jetzigen zustand offiziell soll es ihm
den umständen entsprechend gut gehen wir
haben wir auch gehört momentan mit dem
dsi wir und einem noch experimentellen
antikörper cocktail behandelt spricht
das dafür dass die lage doch ernster ist
wenn er so ein medikament bekommt das
eigentlich von seinen eigenen behörden
noch gar nicht erlaubt worden ist noch
gar nicht auf dem markt ist
das sehe ich ganz genauso also die sache
ist einfach die sie würden nicht dem
us-präsidenten irgendetwas nach dem
motto wir versuchen uns mal rein kippen
wenn es nicht indiziert ist also sprich
es muss sein
was glauben sie wenn er an den da
irgendwelche nebenwirkungen hat er wird
kein arzt mehr glücklich werden
also man muss ganz klar sagen es muss
wirklich eine ernste situation gewesen
sein sonst hätten die kollegen in den
usa das nicht gemacht und man muss klar
sagen mit diesem rennen sie den wir wie
aber auch mit diesen im urin cocktails
sind wir am ende der fahnenstange was
wir direkt gegen den virus machen können
das sind wirksamer medikamente dass eine
wirksame therapie und man muss auch so
sagen das rennen sie die wir hat dann
erfolg oder positiven effekt weil es
relativ frühzeitig eingesetzt wird und
ich denke die kolleginnen usa haben
gesagt wir setzen jetzt alles an weil
die situation
suboptimal ist nicht besonders gut und
deswegen geben wir alles und wirklich
alles auszuprobieren und alles zu tun
vielen dank doktor thomas aßmann für
diese einschätzung und erklärung
dankeschön
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich jedes nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren